[Music]
get a grip the sky isn't falling it's
getting sucked into outer space and so
are all the oceans and the trees and
cars and roads and bridges and the
Earth's core and you so get a grip and
hold on tight you're in for a wild ride
this is what if and here's what would
happen if we lost gravity for five
seconds unless you're an astronaut you
probably don't spend a lot of time
thinking about gravity we all take
gravity for granted and it would be hard
not to aside from a tiny sliver of the
world's population most humans don't
know a life without gravity from the
universe to our solar system to each
planet all the way down to our own
bodies gravity holds everything together
but since we tend to see gravity as a
given it's hard to imagine just how
helpless we would be without it until
it's actually gone gravity is an
attractive force between any two masses
the greater the mass the greater the
gravity the greater the gravity the
stronger to pull gravity is the reason
why Earth rotates around the Sun why we
experience high and low tide and why we
can walk on this planet without floating
away most importantly though gravity
secures our atmosphere holding in the
air we need to breathe in fact there are
a lot of things we can thank gravity for
so many though that if we tried to list
them all here we'd probably end up with
a video longer than Titanic so just to
give you an idea of how important
gravity is in a really really short
amount of time we're going to take it
away from you but not for too long
just five seconds
are you ready with the world's still
spinning at its usual 1600 kilometer per
hour speed everything that isn't secured
firmly to the ground would go flying
cars boats trains planes well obviously
but not like they normally do more like
this the earth spins faster along the
equator so the impact of zero gravity
would be felt hardest there at the
equator you could experience winds
almost six times stronger than the ones
produced by Hurricane Katrina
that means that in just five seconds you
could be blown as far as 2.3 kilometers
in any direction and not just you there
will be plenty of people objects and
animals to look out for
not to mention trees soil and midair
floods from the world's ponds lakes
rivers and oceans at the same time the
gases in the atmosphere would drift out
into space not only are we now losing
huge amounts of oxygen but the sudden
and sharp drop in air pressure would
instantly shatter everyone's inner ears
and then there's the planet itself which
is literally held together by gravity
without gravity the pressure of the
Earth's inner core would cause the
planet to expand it's not like five
seconds without gravity would cause the
world to explode but even a five second
expansion of the Earth's inner core
would cause some major earthquakes and
trigger huge volcanic eruptions add one
more item to your list of dangerous
things flying through the sky lava out
in space the planets in our solar system
that normally orbit the Sun would
instead start drifting away from it
earth would follow its neighbors at a
speed of 30 km/s in just five seconds it
would have traveled 150 kilometers
that's not far enough for our planet to
be out of the habitable zone but how
habitable would Earth be after five
deadly seconds without gravity
when gravity was restored you'd hit the
ground hard if the impact didn't kill
you or if you weren't crushed by a heavy
object you would still be severely
injured my back my back hopefully you'd
catch your breath in time with gravity
pulling oxygen back down to earth and
bringing the atmosphere back around the
planet but there would still be
earthquakes and volcanic eruptions as
the Earth's core becomes compressed
again and there would still be massive
flooding due to the significant
displacement of the oceans the number of
casualties would be astronomical
not just from flying debris lack of
oxygen or simultaneous natural disasters
but because in those five seconds
without gravity the Earth's crust
literally opened up and swallowed
several major cities so yeah a lot can
happen in just five seconds and that
just goes to show how essential gravity
is to life on Earth
and beyond you may think you're special
and you most certainly are but just
remember that you're part of something
bigger than you and that's what keeps
you grounded but don't sink too low can
you imagine how heavy you'd be if
Earth's gravity doubled well that's a
story for another what if
[Music]